seit monaten brennt es in australien und
das deutlich extremer als sonst in der
buschfeuer saison millionen hektar
stehen ganz aktuell in flammen und wir
sprechen heute mit einem wissenschaftler
der sich hauptberuflich mit brandon
auseinandersetzt und der sagt dass wir
das was wir da jetzt gerade erleben das
wird es immer häufiger geben wir müssen
uns auf ein zeitalter des feuers
einstellen wenn ihr fragen dazu habt
dann postet sie wie immer gerne hier
unten in die kommentare
und wir schauen jetzt erstmal ganz
aktuell auf die situation in australien
[Musik]
und live zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
unser korrespondent norm und aal der
mittel in sydney stets normen bei euch
ist es früher in der morgenstunde normal
gibt so ist es gut morgen morgen genau
was mir da sagen die brände die sind ja
nah an sydney herangerückt wie
bedrohlich ist denn jetzt gerade die
lage dort weil um dich herum sieht es ja
eigentlich ganz ruhig auf das muss ich
wohl zu geben das ist ein ruhiger ein
schöner morgen hier in sydney sehr
entspannt und bedrohlich ist die
situation heute in sydney ganz
sicherlich nicht die letzten tage und
wochen sagen oftmals anders aus wenn
dichter rauch hier in der stadt stand
und das leben der menschen wirklich
stark beeinträchtigt hat gesundheit
nicht sicherlich auch viele gefahren mit
sich gebracht hat das hat sie heute
morgen nicht weil der wind günstig wenn
er für sie günstig wird dann ist er
anderswo ungünstig in melbourne zum
beispiel der nächsten großen metropole
südwestlich von hier sieht es ganz
anders aus die haben heute qualm die
haben heute nebel
da sind die menschen wieder mit
schutzmasken unterwegs also da lässt es
sich wieder kaum atmen
wie gesagt das ist ein bisschen ein
lotteriespiel je nachdem wie der wind
weht so ist auch die belastung für die
menschen ganz anders dann natürlich noch
mal in den brandgebieten selbst da sie
teilweise immer noch sehr sehr
bedrohlich aus mehr als 100 vorjahr sind
noch aktiv sagt die feuerwehr
das waren mal mehr das waren schon mal
150 und mehr aber die zahl der vorher
insgesamt sagt da nicht unbedingt das
über die lage auswahl aus mehreren
kleineren feuern größere feuer geworden
sind und die sind unter umständen dann
noch schwerer für die einsatzkräfte zu
kontrollieren also insgesamt gibt es
hier keinerlei grund zur entwarnung oder
durchzuatmen
das ist das bestenfalls was vielleicht
möglich ist ein durchatmen aber
insgesamt bleibt die lage sehr
bedrohlich du sprichst ja jetzt schon
die feuerwehr an die es ja im prinzip
seit monaten im dauereinsatz
mit welchen problemen haben denn die
einsatzkräfte am meisten zu kämpfen
im dauereinsatz fängst glaube ich schon
an tatsächlich seit monaten sind sie
unterwegs versuchen ihr bestes um diese
feuer einzudämmen mehr ist das ja
meistens nicht mehr leisten kann sie
kaum löschen
dazu ist dieses ausmaß der brände viel
zu gewaltig man versucht die feuer
einzudämmen zu begrenzen schaden zu
begrenzen umzuleiten klein zu halten und
das eben fordert schon alle mächtig
heraus und man muss ja auch wissen dass
es nur ein teil der einsatzkräfte sind
die professionell arbeiten alle anderen
sind freiwillige die sich gemeldet haben
darunter sind junge frauen darunter sind
alte männer viele renten haben wir auch
gesehen
die wirklich unbedingt mithelfen wollen
sich für die feuerwehr für die
freiwillige feuerwehr gemeldet haben und
dort eben seit wochen und monaten
tatsächlich kämpfen sie drücken so
drastisch aus und dieses wort passt dann
auch in vielen bereichen und das bringt
für jeden einzelnen eigentlich neue
probleme mit sich also wer sich
freiwillig meldet muss unter umständen
auf seinen job verzichten es gibt nur
wenige die dann unterstützungszahlungen
bekommen die so über die runden kommen
andere erzählen uns auch ich muss dem
bank kredit aufnehmen damit ich hier
weiter kämpfen kann sozusagen
und da gibt es auch noch das problem für
arbeitslose die sich gemeldet haben die
in dieser zeit nicht die möglichkeit
haben sich auch jobs zu bewerben und den
dafür vielleicht dann sogar
unterhaltszahlungen
unterstützungszahlungen gestrichen
werden also das sind alles einzelfälle
die man glaube ich aus dem auge nicht
verlieren sollte wenn man mit großem
respekt hier beobachtet wie sie alle
kämpfen wie sie auch mit der
traumatischen belastung leben die bilder
die sie da jeden tag durchstehen müssen
die sind ja nun wirklich nicht einfach
zu verarbeiten riesige verbrannte fläche
verbrannte tiere überall und einige
dieser menschen die irgendwo gegenfeuer
kämpfen wissen dass zeitgleich ihr
eigenes zuhause bedrohtes vielleicht
verlieren sie es sogar also das sind
ungeheure belastungen die sie
durchstehen müssen gibt es denn irgend
ein lichtblick dass sich die situation
bald verändern könnte ein
wetterumschwung oder ähnliches
lichtblick das müsste eigentlich
tatsächlich vom wetter her kommen
tatsächlich warten alle natürlich
aufregend zwischendurch immer mal ein
paar schauer gegeben die haben nicht
viel gebracht die haben höchstens dafür
gesorgt dass es eine verschnaufpause gab
dass die vorher sich nicht so schnell
haben weiter ausbreiten können aber es
reichte nicht aus um die feuer zu
löschen
in den nächsten tagen könnte es
tatsächlich etwas mehr regen geben für
city ist das vorhergesagt aber auch für
die brandgebiete teilweise nur das
richtige maß das wird eine große
herausforderung sein und die große frage
ob es soweit kommt auf das richtige maß
an regen sozusagen zusammenkommt man
rechnet damit dass in einigen bereichen
starke stürme auftreten können gewitter
starkregen sogar das wäre natürlich
wieder ganz neue probleme
wir wissen auch von der feuerwehr dass
wenn es zu stark regnet dass die
schweren einsatzfahrzeuge dann mitunter
schwierigkeiten haben durchzukommen
also das ist eine heikle geschichte wie
das mit dem wetter weiter geht jeden tag
gucken alle sehr lange darauf und frage
sich bringt kommt es zu regenfällen wird
das der richtige regen sein wird ist die
richtige menge an regen seien aber das
bleibt ein banger blick von tag zu tag
und wir beobachten dass weiter ganz
herzlichen dank neuem und ahlbach sydney
und wie groß das ausmaß der brände ist
das zeigt uns jetzt jochen spieß und
blickt dabei auch auf deutschlands
australien brennt naja auf der karte
wirken die aktuellen brandherde erst mal
relativ übersichtlich doch australien
ist zwanzigmal größer als deutschland
und wenn man die bisher verbrannte
fläche eins zu eins auf deutschland
umlegt wären baden württemberg und
bayern schon komplett zerstört also ganz
süddeutschland verkohlt mindestens die
feiert oben gar nicht mal in den
heißesten gegenden australiens schauen
wir in die gegend der australischen
hauptstadt canberra new south wales und
victoria im südosten eigentlich eher
eine gemäßigte klima zone ähnlich wie
zum beispiel frankfurt am main auf der
südhalbkugel ist jetzt sommer
die höchsttemperaturen in der
betroffenen gegend liegen normalerweise
um die 30 grad
doch schon ende 2009 10 im australischen
frühling herrschten dort extreme wärme
und trockenheit die fehlende
feuchtigkeit im boden wurde zur großen
gefahr so wie übrigens auch im deutschen
rekord sommer 2018 und 2019 die
waldbrandgefahr dadurch riesig bei
rekordhitze frankfurt lag bei 40,2 grad
canberra brach jetzt ebenso seinen
hitzerekord mit 44 grad und durch die
rauchwolken ist sie derzeit eine der
städte mit der größten luftverschmutzung
die krasse hitze kommt mit starken
winden aus den riesigen wüsten zonen des
kontinents ziemlich ungebremst bist an
die südostküste australiens voran
bei uns starten die hitzewellen zwar
auch in der wüste der sahara doch neben
den alpen schlecht vor allem das
mittelmeer meistens die temperatur
deutlich ab solche starken puffer fehlen
in den weiten australiens er an die eine
milliarde säugetiere vögel und reptilien
sollen schon den feuern zum opfer
gefallen sein
gerade die koalas können sich in den
brennenden eukalyptuswälder nicht
schnell genug retten
auch die kleineren waldtiere bei uns
hätten wohl wenig chancen einem solchen
flammen inferno zu entkommen
australien liegt am anderen ende der
welt und zeigt uns für europa trotzdem
was wetter extreme in zeiten des
klimawandels anrichten können
und live zugeschaltet ist merz professor
johann georg goldammer leiter des
zentrums für feuer überwachung des max
planck instituts für chemie guten abend
herr goldammer schön grün gold einmal
warum brennt ist denn gerade in diesem
extremen ausmaß ich denke wir haben in
den beiden beiträgen von normen odenthal
und in dem filmbeitrag gesehen dass hier
in australien eine ganz besondere
situation vor herrscht und das ist
tatsächlich ein extremer sommer der wird
sozusagen angefacht durch die sehr
heißen und trockenen winde die aus dem
inland kommen und das hat in den letzten
wochen und monaten eine situation
geschaffen die dieses extreme feuer
verhalten diese großflächigen bränden
und teilweise eben auch diese feuer
stürme erklärt sie sprechen ja von einem
zeitalter des feuers müssen uns also
auch in deutschland auf immer extremere
brände einstellen
nun der klimawandel hat uns ja schon die
ersten signale sehr deutliche signale
gesendet wir haben das in deutschland
2018 und in einigen teilen nicht überall
deutsch in deutschland 2009 10 wieder
gesehen
dass die trockenzeiten verbunden mit
hitzewellen tatsächlich länger werden
intensiver werden das beobachten wir in
anderen kontinenten genauso wie auch in
australien und der vergleich deutschland
mit der region von südostaustralien ja
der vergleich bietet sich schon an dass
man hier mal parallelen zieht auch wenn
hier aus der gesamten geografie
unterschiede sind aber ich denke dass
wir hier in deutschland auch auf uns
darauf vorbereiten müssen dass wir
weiterhin solche extrem trockenzeiten
bekommen wie wir sie schon hatten und da
müssen wir uns darauf einstellen in
hinblick auf die gefährdung durch große
und schwerer zu bekämpfende landschafts
brände
ich schaue ihr grabmal in die kommentare
bei uns und bei youtube ist ein
kommentar zu finden da schreibt jemand
was war denn in 1992 und bezieht sich
damit auf die weiteren katastrophe bei
weißwasser in sachsen wo es drei wochen
lang gebrannt hat warum gab es denn in
dem jahr so viele große brände also im
prinzip das argument aber gab es das
nicht eigentlich schon immer das ist
stark gebrannt hat nun ja wir haben
ausreise gehabt und wenn wir noch ein
paar jahre zuvor auf die 70er jahre nach
niedersachsen blicken wo wir die große
waldbrand katastrophe hatten die ja mit
über 8.000 hektar das war eine
größenordnung die wir für deutschland
damals für westdeutschland besonders
groß tatsächlich wir hatten diese großen
brand lagen schon mal aber insgesamt ist
es doch so dass der die situation 1992
irgendwie eine ausnahme geblieben ist
und wir hatten in den jahren zuvor und
dann auch vor allen dingen in den jahren
jetzt danach also fast 30 jahre
doch eine situation die relativ ruhig
war die brandflächen waren sehr gering
und da hat sich dann sozusagen dieses
thema so ein bisschen vom bildschirm und
auch von dem bewusstsein entfernt und
das kommt jetzt wieder
jetzt noch mal auf die ganz aktuelle
situation in australien aber ich meine
das hat im vergangenen jahr an ganz
verschiedenen stellen ja auf der welt
gebrannt auch hier in deutschland mal
wieder wenn wir da jetzt noch mal drauf
schauen was kann oder was muss getan
werden um solche brände besser zu
verhindern
nun die menschen in deutschland und in
australien leben ja in einem mix von
naturlandschaften von kulturlandschaften
teilweise alte kulturlandschaften die
auch nicht mehr alle so bewirtschaftet
werden wie früher
und daran müssen sich die
siedlungsgebiete und die
industriegebiete und überall dort wo das
feuer etwas zum brennen vorfindet dann
brennt es über diese verschiedenen
landschaftselemente hinweg das sehen wir
ganz besonders in australien denn die
feuer brennen da wo auch menschen wohnen
und arbeiten oder sogar ferien machen
und hier in deutschland haben wir das
jahr 2018 ganz drastisch erlebt als
beispielsweise zum ersten mal seit
langer zeit brände entlang der bahn bei
siegburg entstanden die viele häuser
verbrannten und dann ja im späteren
verlauf des jahres siedlung südlich von
berlin und dann dieses jahr auch wieder
darum 2009/10 im juli bei lübtheen das
waren doch situationen die hat man
vorher nicht aber was müsste jetzt ganz
konkret getan werden weil sie sie
sprechen von einem zeitalter des feuers
auf das man sich irgendwie auch
einstellen muss wie stellt man sich
darauf ein was muss man denn anders
machen
ja wenn man das erstmal auf ein ganz
einfaches prinzip reduziert wir müssen
wenn wir unsere landschaft insgesamt
bewirtschaften und versicherer feuer
resilient machen wollen dann müssen wir
dem feuer bevor es kommt die nahrung
entziehen
und da schauen wir mal auf die alten
traditionellen verfahren der
landbewirtschaftung intensive land und
weidewirtschaft intensive nutzung der
der produktivität an pflanzlicher
biomasse zb früher zum heizen und kochen
das ist ein bisschen in vergessenheit
geraten als wir alle öl und gas
verwendeten und kohle als energieträger
es kommt heute wieder zurück
nachwachsende pflanzliche biomasse als
quelle erneuerbarer energie zu verwenden
und dann würden wir sie dem
unkontrollierten feuer entziehen
und wir müssen unsere wälder die ja sich
im wandel befinden die waldgesellschaft
wie hier die unterliegen ganz enormen
klima stress und wir sehen das an
großflächigen absterben von vielen
baumarten in deutschland da müssen wir
in hinblick auf eine gezielte
forstwirtschaft die genau sich dieses
thema vor nimmt nämlich nicht nur die
erhaltung des waldes in hinblick auf
biodiversität erhaltung oder produktion
sondern auf widerstandsfähigkeit gegen
feuer und das bedeutet dass die wälder
in zukunft vielleicht etwas anders
aussehen müssen wir müssen die wälder
aussehen da müssen sie jetzt mal
konkreter werden ja schauen wir doch mal
in regionen die schon seit langen
zeitraum von natürlichen feuern
teilweise auch vom menschen verursachten
feuern sich entwickelt haben
das wäre zum beispiel südosten der usa
die großen lichten kiefernwälder die
dort natürlich sind oder fallen in
zentralasien in sibirien und da hat das
feuer etwas gemacht mit einer
vorherrschende baumart in der
sogenannten hellen tiger das ist genau
die gleiche kiefer narr die hier in
deutschland wächst die hat das feuer
dort über jahrhunderte und jahrtausende
immer wieder sozusagen aufgeräumt sie
auf gelichtet und wir finden heute in
der in der hellenthaler finden wir
weiter offen ständige parkartige
sogenannte licht wälder
da stehen pro flächeneinheit sehr viel
weniger bäume
es ist auch nicht so viel brennmaterial
da weil immer wieder kleine blitzschlag
feuer dieses brennmaterial rausholen das
kann man kontrolliert durch
kontrollierte brände nachahmen und so
besteht die möglichkeit mit einigen
bauern haben übrigens zählen auch da die
eukalyptus dazu die in australien
wachsen wenn man die gezielt dahingehend
bewirtschaftet dass sie eben in einem
wald gefüge aufwachsen wo weniger
brennbares material weniger konkurrenz
weniger bäume dann können diese wälder
dem feuer auch besser standhalten
also ich fasse man zusammen weniger
pflanzte wälder und dann fällt auch mal
zwischendurch kontrollierte feuer um das
unterwallis quasi da rauszuholen
das ist jetzt wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe ich hab mal das ist
richtig das heißt ja ich hab mal ganz
kurz ihren die kommentare reingeschaut
und hier ist ein kommentar von alexander
der übt kritik an der politik und
schreibt unter anderem oder stellt unter
anderem die frage das zeitalter des
feuers fragezeichen sagen wir besser das
zeitalter der weniger begabten hat die
politik dieses problem genug auf den
schirm ich für die frage an sie
weitergeben
also offensichtlich hat die politik das
problem noch nicht auf dem schirm habe
es ist allein in den letzten zwei jahren
doch deswegen auf den schirm gerückt
weil die zivilgesellschaft die
öffentlichkeit die medien dieses thema
doch sehr viel energischer angegangen
haben wie die politik selbst sehen wir
auch bei der ganzen debatte um den
klimawandel in der sich jetzt die
zivilgesellschaft einbringt freddys for
future und auf diese aufmerksamkeit hin
und auf diesen druck hin reagiert die
politik ich denke mal das beispiel von
australien dass der premier jetzt
eingelenkt hat und vor wenigen tagen nun
eingeräumt hat dass der klimawandel nun
doch existent ist das hat er ja bisher
weitgehend geleugnet und dass die
politik sich darauf einstellen muss das
ist halt die jüngere entwicklung und ich
gehe mal davon aus dass wir alle
kollektiv darauf hinarbeiten müssen dass
die politik all diesen entwicklungen
auch folgt und wenn es bisher
tatsächlich nicht in ausreichendem maße
geschehen ist dann ja dann ist es
allerhöchste eisenbahn
lassen sie uns jetzt einmal abschließend
auf die folgen dieser feuer schauen
die kommen nämlich sehr sehr viele
fragen sowohl bei facebook als auch bei
twitter und youtube zu dem thema ja was
passiert denn danach den wäldern hier
martin fragt zum beispiel was werden die
folgen sein
dann gibt es hier eine frage von klarer
wie lange dürfte es dauern bis sich die
abgebrannten wäldern
strahlend und hier in deutschland
erholen ja um auf die frage von klarer
zurückzukommen
da haben wir sicher ganz große
unterschiede im moment noch zwischen
deutschland und australien in australien
besteht die ganz große gefahr dass durch
die tatsächlich sehr rasante und extreme
veränderung des klimas möglicherweise
das wissen wir aber heute noch nicht
nach dem feuer nach diesen großflächigen
und sehr intensiven bränden sich die
alte vegetation und damit auch die
tierwelt nicht wieder einstellt und das
vielleicht doch obwohl in australien und
diese feier eigentlich auch schon seit
jahrhunderten und jahrtausenden brennen
sich hier eine änderung ergibt dass wir
nach dem feuer nicht mehr die situation
von vor dem feuer haben wenn ich mal
kurz auf deutschland zu sprechen komme
natürlich wir haben ja in den letzten
jahrzehnten immer wieder waldbrände
gehabt auch wenn sie nicht groß waren
und wenn sie nachher im solchem wald
band zwei bis drei jahre später mal auf
die flächen gegangen sind dann wurden
die sehr systematisch geräumt wieder
aufgeforstet und dann konnte sie
praktisch eigentlich nichts mehr sehen
von den waldbränden
das wird in deutschland sicherlich
weiter so bleiben wir haben sehr
intensive forstwirtschaft wir haben gut
erschlossenes land ein hohes interesse
unsere wälder bei allen möglichen
ereignis das können wir auch stürme und
orkane sein windwurf und windbruch
wieder in ordnung zu kriegen aber wenn
wir das insgesamt auf der ganzen welt wo
solche infrastrukturen und solches
leistungspotenzial wie beispiel
beispielsweise von der forstwirtschaft
nicht da sind dann besteht wirklich die
gefahr dass dieses zusammenwirken von
klimawandel und feuer und das ist ja
eigentlich auch diese theorie von dem
zeitalter des feuers von dem büro 10
das als konsequenz der verbrennung
fossiler energieträger nun die
atmosphäre und das klima zurückschlägt
und hier bedingungen schafft dass die
vegetation der erde die landschaften der
erde
aufgrund dieses vom menschen verursacht
weil es eben leichter häufiger und
intensiver brennen und was danach kommt
das hängt davon ab wie wirklich das
klima sich weiterentwickelt und ich sehe
da schon eine reihe von problemen auf
uns zukommen das waren die
einschätzungen von professor johann
georg goldammer
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für das
gespräch
danke schön und ich bedanke ich
natürlich auch bei euch für das fleißige
mit kommentieren und fragen stellen der
nächsten live stream gibt es die nächste
woche dann mit daniel und wir würden
natürlich freuen wenn ihr auch wieder
dabei sein
[Musik]
und wenn euch dieser live-stream
gefallen hat dann interessiert euch
vielleicht auch dieser hier
da ging es darum ob man mit hightech den
klimawandel stoppen kann oder der hier
da ging es darum ob das waldsterben in
deutschland überhaupt noch zu stoppen
ist oder ihr klickt euch mal hier rein
und lasst uns ein abo da
[Musik]